you talk about you know you want unity
and how we can't have this polarization
it's not the people we got to blame
somebody else
you have high profile verified influence
influential personalities with you know
millions of followers
who are cheering
for the complete destruction of the
american form of government
that we have a checks and balance that
that we have checks and balances that we
have an executive legislative and a
judicial branch all equally powerful
calling each other out when they break
when they when they step out of the line
right now you have
many people i mean just go on twitter
you can see them all these are the
people on the left in the establishment
celebrating that what joe celebrating
what joe biden did
on numerous occasions bypassing the
american way of government these people
are acting against the american way of
government
let me explain something
when barack obama you know he wants to
do daca right deferred action for
childhood rivals i think it's what it
means
there's a question over
well
the president can give orders to the
executive branch and how they handle
certain cases so there's a legal
question there
if you and a lot of people argue this is
legislation obama should not be able to
do this and then others argued well he
can simply tell ice not to enforce it
because he can instruct them to do it
and that's that's well that's exactly
executive branch and then you've got to
get lawsuits lawsuits have got to get
involved when donald trump wants to have
a travel ban based on you know this list
of countries of of threats
some argue
well that's got to go through
legislation yeah but it's also that the
the the president has the ability to
declare emergencies and take executive
action that's the point of the executive
branch
what joe biden did today
mandating that businesses with 100
employees or more be fined fourteen
thousand dollars if they don't get
weekly tests or verify vaccination is
overtly a legislation thing when joe
biden bypassed a supreme court ruling by
enacting a new eviction moratorium he
directly spat in the face of the supreme
court violating in no uncertain terms
the checks and boundaries of this
country and now you have people on the
left celebrating this
how do we move forward as a country
when
half of the political population because
not every person in america is
celebrating the collapse of the american
way of governance
it's like the left's ideology i say this
all the time on my show
basically the same way you just said it
too
is their their ideology is just a
sliding scale where they can go from we
need to support abortion right to murder
babies in the womb that's my right it's
like the only time they care about their
constitutional right is when it comes to
murdering and aborting babies um but
when it comes to forcefully getting
vaccinated being locked in the house all
this all that that comes with it for
public health and public safety all of a
sudden the constitution doesn't exist
your rights don't exist but it's it's
just like they have well their whole
entire ideology is a sliding scale with
no consistencies and about what benefits
them at that moment at that time but
it's also
you know i i think you'll understand
this ian
we cannot be a a a civilization of
people
fighting for 100 safety
it's impossible
but that seems to be what the left right
now is saying sacrifice everything for
more safety we saw it in the colleges
when they created the safe spaces if a
lecturer says a naughty word and you're
offended here is a pastel room full of
stuffed animals and bean bags for you to
go crying
those are real things oh big tech
companies had safe spaces for when trump
won the election that's like oh they
were crying yeah so these are people who
are voting and enforcing safety safety
safety above all else after january 6 i
know a bunch of people that work for
companies and their companies had uh
mental health days after the january
session i remember that yeah yeah a lot
of a lot of that and they still have
mental health days whenever something
big happens in the news
which is utterly and pathetic in my book
but we're watching this happen
that safety has become paramount over
everything else and what did ben
franklin say
those that would sacrifice
freedom for for temporary security
deserve neither and will lose both and
here's the thing is us republicans or
people on the right we don't care what
people on the left do like me personally
i would rather us just kind of split you
live your life let me live my life but
it's they can't let that happen
they want to force us to live by the
rules that they want
them to live by
it's like they can't just say hey can we
just all just throw ourselves in florida
just leave us alone like we'll all just
stay in these states stop telling us
what to do just leave us alone we won't
bother you you won't bother us
but they know and i think it comes down
to a lot of like the truck drivers and
the unions they kind of need us for that
and california is always like oh we have
the biggest economy in the state well
let's say that's a comedy in the world
but why does it mean best why would
anyone give up their surfs
yeah you know so you've got eastern
oregon wanting to secede from the state
it's like we don't need ammo why would
why would portland
allow their serfs who pay taxes to to
leave the state
no i don't know we need those resources
we need that access to the leverage
yeah but but you've seen it right
i mean the constant drive towards safety
we can't do that we can't live that way
people think
seems that people think this that the
covet is is deadly like smallpox or like
or like uh polio like it's like it's a
debilitating crippling disease it's not
good for you and it definitely seems to
have detrimental effects but to act like
it's pull like it's as dangerous as
polio i i get it suspend habeas corpus
if there's a life-threatening
devastating virus that's causing people
to fall down their arms are rotting off
they're bleeding out of their face
you call you call up off you call off
habeas corpus and you
you heal the people with whatever you
have but that's not what we saw we saw a
a
incredibly transmissible disease that's
what is it 99.4 percent of the people
that get it i think come out of it okay
i think that's the number
is that people who tested or people who
actually these of cases of confirmation
99 over 99 of the people are coming out
okay and now the cdc has said twice as
many people have been infected as per
previously that would be 99.5 well it it
it doesn't change i was i was reading
about this it doesn't change case
fatality but the point is
a lot it means a lot of people have
gotten this didn't realize it and i'll
tell you this you know we've had people
on the show and when you actually have
someone explain to you like what getting
covert was like you really don't want to
get it i've had the flu
and the flu was it was a nightmare i
lost 20 pounds overnight yeah i was
shaking i was pale i used to kill people
oh yeah i thought back then you knew you
had the flu you knew you were going to
be fine i had no no no no no you thought
you were actually going to dude i lost
20 pounds overnight i was like i need to
go to hospital i'll say well here's me
but here's the point but here's the
point i wanted to make that when it
comes to covid you hear about you know
we had someone on the show explaining
how all of a sudden one day he couldn't
breathe anymore he couldn't have a
conversation he's like i gotta go to the
hospital we had john pierce on the show
and then a month later he's in the
hospital because like so so that's
that's something to consider it is it is
more it is i think it's twice as deadly
or it's
more deadly than the flu we're dealing
with something different now with the
variance they're more infectious there's
long-term effects
they're not as deadly i don't have the
full numbers to pull up but i think
here's where we need to be
covet is scary long-term health effects
for younger people are bad
mortality tends to be for older people
there's some promising studies on
therapeutics and alternative treatments
there's some vaccines hey how about we
be honest about the whole thing not
force people to do it and every time i
see one of these stories where they lie
and they say things like the man grasped
my hand and said please
i just wish i took the wreck i'm like
that didn't happen dude
because there was one woman who claimed
it and then a bunch of people called
like they pulled up the cdc data on the
hospital and found out she made it up oh
my gosh yeah it's like dude no no no one
in these age groups were in your
hospital with kova this is or how about
the the ivermectin thing in oklahoma
when all these outlets fall for it this
is why there are skeptics because the
media lies over and over again is the
oklahoma ivor ivermectin thing where
they said 70 of all the poison control
calls were for people that but then it
turned out two percent seventy percent
of the two percent of the calls
were foreign so like 1.6
of the calls that's a great story we
have yet to go on that on this show did
you talk about the on your no that's
hilarious i was gonna say another thing
is like imagine if covert was actually
as bad as they're saying it
or pretending it is or promoting no no
no no no no we wouldn't be having this
conversation
if the government for the most part
stayed out of it i feel like and i'm
just such a believer in the free markets
and the people and you know people
making the right decisions uh based on
the truth and based on the information i
feel like if there was an actual disease
killing let's say five to ten percent of
the people it touches i feel like we
would make personal
yes changes to our own life it would be
my life's goal to help people joey yeah
covey home that actually seems bad
people my age are dying i'm not gonna go
out listen listen
is exactly as bad as they say it is
kovid is absolutely as bad as they've
been saying it is
the problem is they're cowards who want
to live in bubble wrap in a safe space
instead of realizing that freedom comes
with risks so i'm the kind of guy who's
like hey we decided to move out in the
middle of nowhere there are bears out
here
and uh we uh somebody recently was
posting about how like there were bears
outside their houses we get messages
flagged on our facebook group it's like
guys guys there's a bear everyone you
know stay inside wild cats and stuff
yeah welcome to mountains we choose to
live in these areas we have more freedom
and greater risk that's on us the
problem is when you get these people who
see something like covid and then say
shut her down everyone even you in the
middle of nowhere
you work from home vaccine mandate
another thing is like if i died from
covid tomorrow i don't want to be used
politicized as oh he was anti-vaccine or
whatever he should have he only would
have lived if he only took the vaccine
if i die from covert tomorrow another
day that's my choice because i didn't if
i didn't take the vaccine and i died
from it or because i went out and got
myself sick
that's not me you do you got to be real
careful about dying from covet and dying
with code
because some people die from like a
heart attack and they have covet and
then they get countered
one of the biggest spins that they did i
think it was in california when when it
first started there was like an 18 year
old 17 year old kid uh died with covid
but apparently he was doing steroids and
his like heart exploded and they tested
him and he had coveted and they ran the
headlines 17 year old high school
student
young healthy played football died with
from covid however they did the smith
try to scare younger people at the time
they do it with you know when a baby
dies from coveted too they do all these
spins you read the article and you go
down to the bottom you're like oh okay
so that's the truth
but they got the headline out thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you